before we start we just want to say
thank you to our sponsor semper
for sponsoring this video recently i
discovered that i can try a new designer
fragrance every month for just 16
a month through scentbird's fragrance
subscription service and the amazing
thing about semper is that they carry
over 600 different brands
including prada gucci burberry and a
bunch of indie labels too
semper actually sent us a bunch of
different brands including tommy bahama
i got lacoste chloe from my wife and
actually
found that they had my personal favorite
which was lacoste essential
this is a scent that i discovered many
many years ago and recently was about to
run out of
they send you these kind of easy to use
really cool containers that are easy to
travel with and they carry 30 days worth
in case you're having trouble deciding
which fragrance is right for you
scentbird actually has its own quiz that
you can fill out and based on that quiz
your preferences and also what you've
bought in the past
they'll actually suggest the scent that
they think will be right for you
honestly it's easy to use and it's also
kind of risk-free if you're like me
sometimes it's scary or hard to
spend a lot of money on a big bottle of
cologne or perfume that you don't even
know if you're gonna like
but this is an amazing way to try a lot
of different scents and find
what's perfect for you and if you don't
like it you can always cancel
with no risk but if you love it or if
you want to try a lot of different
scents you can actually upgrade to two
or even three different fragrances a
month
if you're interested make sure you check
out sembert in the description below
if you use the code jubilee you'll
actually get five dollars off
your purchase and your first month will
only be eleven dollars we hope you check
it out we hope you smell
amazing we hope you enjoy the video i
don't know if i'm more afraid of
meeting 20 people or being in front of
cameras i don't know which one's worse
[Music]
it's almost as if it's only about you
just teenagers right they don't have to
worry about anything else they don't
have to worry about no bills then at the
same time
we have things like parents involved
there's school going on
still so it's like interesting
[Music]
so as for physical attributes i usually
you know prefer someone that is
shorter than me but uh i'm
five nine if i strap on some basketball
shoes maybe i'm 5 10.
[Applause]
in terms of like their their build and
whatnot i don't have too much of a
preference
so much so that they're okay with my
build i guess you could say
[Music]
i've been with about three people was
in high school and um very
unpredictable as many high school
relationships are
everybody has things to learn from their
first relationship the fact that matters
that people's
first ones aren't always the best one
and i would just
rather not be that first one
[Music]
more often than not i find that like my
like social battery sort of like
runs out faster than most people uh but
i still like to
go out and like be with people be around
people spend time with people
sometimes i can be a little bit like i
get too comfortable with with not
exploring and not seeing new things and
um sometimes it'd be nice to have
somebody that could you know
drag me out to things or like convince
me to to try something new
[Music]
[Applause]
if you had a deal breaker in terms of
love languages what
love language are you not looking for i
think definitely
like receiving gifts and then anything
around the
idea of like materialism right because i
feel like it says a lot about
a person and and what exactly they value
getting gifts and receiving gifts and
giving gifts is like
what they're striving for in life i
think it says a lot
[Music]
hmm
a love language i'd like to give to
partners you know words of affirmation
words can hold a lot of weight sometimes
and people you know need the reassurance
and they need
you know affirming messages
[Music]
hmm
four we're down to four we're down to
four we're still good we're still good
uh hi should we should we should we
stand up yeah yeah yeah
how's this all for you guys it's kind of
scary
i thought she was really funny she did
get um
cut out on the last one about love
languages i think she was the one that
like would fake and stuff like that
and i thought that was really nice or
the part that feels bad is like i don't
exactly like
no know them so it's just like it feels
like i'm already like
cutting that you know possibility off
without getting to fully know them yet
but
do you think that the way that someone
talks through text
can still like reveal about their
personality there are a lot of you know
um
shallow people i guess you could say
right that will uh immediately judge you
just from your appearance um i guess
through text you really do get to
see people for who they are and again
you never know some people really do
feel to themselves when it comes to
texting or they
have a different almost personality
sometimes
when they're texting in comparison to
like being in person you guys um go to
school or you work
yeah i go to school and i go to school
yeah where do you guys go
i go to um yeah that's where i'm going
to get my teaching degree and everything
oh nice i would get really nervous
talking to people in general but it's
like
if i could do this and i can conquer the
world